[Aplausos]
[Música]
amigos la historia que vais a ver a
continuación no es el guión de ninguna
película de detectives de europa del
este es lo que ha pasado lo que está
ocurriendo a día de hoy en el seno de la
política rusa y es que a la federación
rusa del país de las matrioskas el vodka
o la mítica canción kalinga
perfectamente le podríamos sumar el
veneno como otro más de sus rasgos de
identidad característicos y si lo habéis
escuchado bien el veneno por ejemplo
estoy convencido que todos habéis
escuchado historias como estas el ruso
naval ni cayó enfermo tras beber agua
embotellada envenenada en su habitación
de hotel según sus colaboradores naval
neide el cual por cierto os hablamos
hacernos mucho en visor político se ha
convertido en algo así como el principal
enemigo del presidente vladimir putin
dentro de la política rusa un enemigo
que ha obsesionado a putin más y más a
medida que este personaje ha sido capaz
de unir a la oposición y crear la que
posiblemente es la alternativa más
fuerte al mandatario ruso en mucho
muchísimo tiempo os dejamos por cierto
por aquí abajo la descripción del vídeo
que hicimos hace poco sobre este
político ruso pues bien el caso amigos
es que os hará enfrentarse al poderoso
vladimir putin tiene sus riesgos en un
país donde el estado de derecho brilla
prácticamente por su ausencia y los
servicios secretos hacen lo que les
viene en gana no debería
y la eliminación de opositores sea algo
frecuente
hablamos de ataques contra personas
influyentes como políticos periodistas
activistas e incluso artistas que no
comulgan con el gobierno ataques que ojo
no sólo suceden en solo los rusos sino
también en el extranjero probablemente
muchos recordéis el caso de los
envenenamientos de sergei y giulia
skripal en xalisco y reino unido- por
parte de dos agentes rusos en 2018 un
ataque para el que utilizaron un agente
nervioso llamado 234 del grupo no [ __ ]
es decir hablamos de que hemos llegado a
ver auténticos ataques con armas
químicas en suelo extranjero con todo lo
que ello supone
ahora bien no penséis ni por un instante
que esto de los envenenamientos es algo
nuevo ya madre rusia hará nada de hecho
estas técnicas forman parte de la
política de este país desde hace mucho
más tiempo del que tal vez os podáis
imaginar por poneros un par de ejemplos
en 1453 el príncipe dmitri se me acaba
fue eliminado envenenando el pollo de su
cena con arsénico en el 610 otro
príncipe ruso mijail copping suisse que
fue envenenado por su propia esposa
porque el zar le consideró una amenaza y
lo cierto es que desde entonces los
envenenamientos han sido una constante
en rusia y de hecho alcanzaron un punto
de perfeccionamiento realmente asombroso
con la llegada de la unión soviética
[Música]
el propio lenin el padre del movimiento
bolchevique ruso impulsó la creación de
una red de laboratorios secretos para
investigar y desarrollar nuevos venenos
y después durante la era de stalin se
fueron sumando muchos más el más famoso
fue el ápex conocido popularmente como
camera el objetivo inicial de estos
laboratorios era probar y perfeccionar
venenos ya existentes un objetivo para
el que no dudaban en utilizar a
prisioneros vivos de gula c's a los que
se envenenaba con gas mostaza ricina
dijk y toxina curar e cianuro entre
otros muchos agentes tóxicos todo esto
al más puro estilo del doctor mengele o
del escuadrón 731 japonés
[Música]
y ojo porque una vez que tuvieron el
conocimiento y la capacidad suficiente
se puso en marcha la que posiblemente es
una de las carreras armamentísticas más
horribles y espeluznantes de toda la era
soviética la de las armas químicas
atentos
herencia soviética más turbia
una pregunta porque el uso de venenos
contra la oposición en rusia es tan
frecuente vale estoy seguro de que no
tenéis la menor duda evidentemente para
quitársela de en medio pero por qué usar
venenos y agentes tóxicos en vez de
otros métodos pues pensarlo un momento
hablamos de un método rápido silencioso
y con unos efectos sobre el organismo
que pueden llegar a aparecer los de una
muerte natural y de hecho los progresos
en la creación de sustancias letales que
pudieran pasar completamente
desapercibidos se sucedieron de forma
muy pero que muy rápida
[Música]
entre 1928 y 1935
los laboratorios secretos soviéticos de
mano del bioquímico grigor y mayra
noveski consiguieron crear un amplio
catálogo de venenos insípidos incoloros
inodoros y metales que podían echarse en
la comida o la bebida sin que la víctima
se diera cuenta de su presencia gracias
a los avances que estaba haciendo mayra
noveski pasó a formar parte del equipo
de pavel subo plato un agente del
servicio secreto soviético en el kv de
que se dedicaba a ejecutar a quien era
considerado como enemigo del estado
y esto esto fue de hecho lo que permitió
a sudo platov ya su equipo cambiar de
modus operandi y pasaron de métodos niza
ros como regalar cajas de bombones con
explosivos a simplemente aderezar un
poco la comida la vida de sus enemigos
con uno de estos venenos era tan simple
que rápidamente le cogieron el gustillo
y esto pasó a convertirse en uno de los
principales métodos de aniquilación
contra la disidencia la unión soviética
y fijaos si se le fue la mano que tras
la muerte de joseph stalin su plato fue
arrestado en el marco de la
desestalinización y se pasó 15 años en
la cárcel claro que a ver los soviéticos
eran conscientes de que los métodos de
este tipo eran eficaces así que a pesar
de la condena lo cierto es que no
tardaron demasiado en dedicar más y más
recursos para desarrollar nuevas
sustancias cada vez más fuertes y
difíciles de rastrear
[Música]
ahora bien por qué demonios necesitaban
otros venenos más discretos pues amigos
la respuesta esta pregunta nos la da el
historiador voice volverse ellos deben
hacer que la muerte o enfermedad de la
víctima parezca natural o al menos
produzca síntomas que desconciertan a
los médicos y forenses para este fin la
cámara desarrolló su especialidad
transformar venenos conocidos en nuevas
armas originales e intratables boris
voladores que claro a medida que
avanzaban los venenos pues también lo
hacían las técnicas médicas y forenses
tal y como ocurre con el doping en el
deporte puede ser una lucha o un
esfuerzo continuo por la superación
comenzó así toda una auténtica carrera
para desarrollar - cada vez más y más
silenciosos y es que hasta entonces a
pesar de todo pues había seguido siendo
relativamente como un emplear métodos
como el del polonio 210 una sustancia
tóxica que deja un amplio rastro de
contaminación reactiva que es fácil de
rastrear con un contador geiger pero
bien el caso es que así fue como se
llegó a la década de 1980 cuando los
soviéticos lanzaron un programa de
desarrollo de agentes nerviosos único en
el mundo amigos había nacido el folk
yang el programa que creó los temidos no
bichos
[Música]
el novillo que literalmente en ruso
significa recién llegado es un grupo de
neurotoxinas altamente letales
desarrolladas por los científicos
soviéticos en laboratorios del norte de
kazajistán uzbekistán y en la propia
rusia en forma de líquido polvo aerosol
se trata de un veneno extremadamente
fácil de transportar a otro país para
eliminar incluso a disidentes exiliados
sin ser detectado en las fronteras
internacionales
este grupo de venenos inhibe la
colinesterasa atacando a los
neurotransmisores que son sustancias de
las células nerviosas que regulan
funciones esenciales del organismo de
este modo se provoca un fallo en algún
órgano esencial que puede ser
enmascarado como una enfermedad fortuita
además estos venenos presentan la
ventaja de que según la dosis empleada
puede servir tanto para acabar con la
vida como para dar sustos o avisos
es decir emplearlo sin llegar a eliminar
al adversario
[Música]
pensar de un momento o un ataque al
corazón quien podía demostrar en la
época soviética que el causante fuese un
agente del estado y no una enfermedad
repentina ya os aseguro yo que nadie es
por este motivo que no se sabe
exactamente a cuánta gente se pudo
cargar la unión soviética- con este tipo
de operaciones secretas contra
opositores y disidentes pero amigos los
programas y los equipos para llevar a
cabo estas operaciones existían así que
seguramente las víctimas se cuenten por
miles
en cualquier caso lo que sí está claro
es que hoy en día este modus operandi
está más vivo que nunca en la rusia de
putin y es que bien por ir de tipo duro
o por ser a ex agente de la caja me
parece que al presidente ruso le encanta
tirar de venenos para demostrar que os
está con él o contra él y de hecho el
fsb el servicio federal de seguridad
ruso no sólo ha heredado las estructuras
sino también los métodos de la caja y
nadie parece querer ni poder hacer nada
para evitarlo pero como es posible que
en pleno siglo 21 y con todos los
avances médicos que se han producido
este arcaico y antiguo método de
eliminación de adversarios sigue
existiendo y otra pregunta se produce
acaso algún tipo de implicación o no se
protesta a la sociedad rusa cuando salen
a la luz casos de este tipo
[Música]
no
nueva rusia viejas costumbres si hay
algo de lo que a putin le gusta presumir
a tus amigos es seguramente de que nadie
se le puede poner por delante los
acontecimientos dentro y fuera de rusia
bajo la presidencia de esta especie de
nuevo zar nos muestran que sus métodos y
su mentalidad no han dejado de
evolucionar cada año que ha estado al
frente del kremlin y es que putin que
llegó a la presidencia rusa en 1999 y
desde entonces en la práctica no ha
abandonado el poder ha ido cruzando cada
vez más y más líneas éticas y morales
por ejemplo en 2004 russian veneno al
expresidente de ucrania el proeuropeo
víctor yúschenko cuando estaba en plena
campaña electoral para ser reelegido
esto se descubrió después de que
yúschenko desarrollará de forma súbita
una pancreatitis aguda a raíz de esto
dos los médicos de viena que le fue
tratado descubrieron en su cuerpo
niveles tan altos de dioxina tc de que
se convirtió en el segundo registro más
alto jamás medido en un ser humano un
par de años después alexander litvinenko
un ex agente de la caja de control ya
putin que residía en londres murió
intoxicado por sustancias reactivas
claro que para entender la posible
relación entre este hecho y el gobierno
ruso pues hay que retroceder apenas un
mes hasta octubre del 2006 cuando la
periodista rusa anna politkóvskaya fue
el tiro
en el ascensor de su apartamento
[Música]
politkovskaya era una periodista
contraria a putin que siempre sorteó las
amenazas la censura y todas las
dificultades que el gobierno ruso le
puso para desempeñar su trabajo hasta
que se metió a investigar crímenes de
putin en chechenia y casos de corrupción
eso aparentemente la convirtió en un
objetivo prioritario había que cerrarle
la boca y de hecho aunque fue asesinada
en octubre de 2006 un par de años antes
fue envenenada con un veneno que a día
de hoy sigue siendo indeterminado cuando
viajaba a bordo de un avión de air flota
la periodista empezó a encontrarse muy
mal después de beber un té a bordo sin
embargo en ese caso la rápida actuación
de la tripulación de un aterrizaje de
emergencia le salvaron la vida
el caso es que alexander litvinenko
decidió desde londres investigar la
muerte en extrañas circunstancias de
esta periodista en el ascensor en su
casa y tan solo un mes después el mismo
murió envenenado el método intoxicación
por polonio-210 después de reunirse en
un hotel londinense con dos rusos que
supuestamente eran agentes de negocio la
agua ya de la radiactividad amigos sin
embargo quedó por toda la habitación y
no sólo eso también en las escuelas del
hotel en una discoteca cercana donde
habían estado los agentes rusos incluso
apareció una toalla cargada de
radioactividad en la lavandería todo eso
de hecho fue precisamente lo que ayuda
la escolanía para saber dónde habían
estado los asesinos y en qué momento se
produjo el envenenamiento
[Aplausos]
sin embargo amigos si esto ya os parece
grave lo cierto es que desde entonces
las cosas pues no han hecho más que
empeorar por ejemplo el activista
opositor a putin y periodista vladimir
cara moza ha sido envenenado en dos
ocasiones en 2015 y en 2017 llegando a
estar gravemente enfermo potter ver si
los activistas de pus y riot perdió
repentinamente la vista el oído y la
movilidad en 2018 y fue confirmado como
envenenado tras viajar a alemania para
tratarse ser gay juliá skripal ese mismo
año fueron envenenados con un agente
nervioso del grupo no [ __ ] que en
salisbury reino unido como ya os
comentábamos al principio del vídeo y
por último al menos que se sepa está el
caso de alexei navalny
como veis se trata de una larga lista de
casos conocidos que se ha acelerado en
los últimos cinco años y luego ya sobre
los casos de envenenamiento dentro del
propio país y sobre personajes pues no
tan destacados como un líder de la
oposición pues eso ya digamos que se
queda en rusia una de las grandes
virtudes del veneno para los crímenes
políticos y es la posibilidad de
combinar la fácil negación y una
teatralidad cruel incluso cuando el
asesino niega a cualquier papel la
víctima muere de una manera horrible ya
menudo prolongada un mensaje en una
botella de veneno
marc galeote y miembro asociado senior
del royal united services institute
porque amigos el elemento principal de
esta historia es que si sabemos lo que
sabemos de estos casos es básicamente
porque o bien se produjeron fuera de
rusia o bien consiguieron salir al
extranjero para recibir tratamientos
médicos cuantos casos más se producen
dentro del país es difícil muy difícil
prácticamente imposible de averiguar
pero vale llegados a este punto la
pregunta que podemos hacernos es y
mientras tanto el gobierno ruso qué
demonios dice
pues imagina obviamente que ellos pues
no saben nada y que no han sido los
autores que puede haber sido cosa de
algún enemigo personal respuestas y sin
embargo no resultan nada convincentes
escuchado he escuchado estos argumentos
durante muchos años desde politkovskaya
litvinenko pasando por script al que
podría no haber sido el kremlin sino
alguien intentando hacer favores al
kremlin el problema con este argumento
es que en 2020 la situación es la que
teníamos en 2004-2006 es realmente
difícil imaginar que alguien se
atreviera a hacer algo tan drástico sin
asegurarse primero de que cuenta con
algún acuerdo para estar seguro de que
está cubierto android son la toffee
experto en servicios de seguridad rusos
y de todo el sentido no os parece pero
vale seguro que también muchos de
vosotros os estaréis preguntando vale
vale enrique pero y la gente qué opinan
los rusos de todo esto
pues bien esa pregunta también es algo
difícil de responder lo cierto es que la
sociedad rusa si algo ha aprendido
durante el último siglo es que cuando se
trata de asuntos de poder pues mejor oír
ver y callar no obstante a pesar de eso
la oposición de navalny cosechó buenos
resultados en las elecciones regionales
del pasado 13 de septiembre de 2000
mente los aliados de naval ni ganaron
por primera vez en la historia diputados
regionales que hicieron perder la
mayoría a rusia unida el partido de
putin en dos ciudades siberianas toms y
nuevos civiles pero en cualquier caso lo
cierto es que expresarse activamente no
sólo es algo extremadamente peligroso
para los rusos en términos de represión
y consecuencias políticas sino que
además difícilmente van a poder
encontrarán para el 'apagón informativo'
en este aspecto es prácticamente total
así que ya lo veis una de las
consecuencias de salirse del guión son
ni más ni menos que las que habéis visto
en este vídeo desde aquí y de parte de
todo el equipo de visual político
nuestro recuerdo y nuestro homenaje para
todas esas personas que han perdido la
vida o se la han jugado luchando por
lograr una argucia más libre y
democrática pero amigos llegados a este
turno turno para ti cómo crees que
debería actuar la comunidad
internacional ante los envenenamientos
contra la oposición rusa debería acaso
considerarse una violación
las operaciones rusas para acabar con la
vida de opositores en el extranjero como
siempre en nuestras son las preguntas y
vuestras las respuestas si este vídeo se
resultó interesante y no olvides dar al
botón de like y dejarnos un comentario
con vuestra opinión por aquí abajo y por
supuesto si aún no lo habéis hecho
suscribiros a visual política una vez
más muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]